so I don't want to Overdo the polling discussions.
We've only been talking about polling like
every couple of weeks.
Recently.
There's some really interesting things going
on in the polls that make me want to talk
about it again today.
Joe Biden has again had another really bad
week in polling.
He keeps dropping and the beneficiary this
week of Biden dropping in the polls has been
Elizabeth Warren rather than some of the other,
uh, um, uh, historical beneficiaries.
Like for example, Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth
Warren is climbing again and actually starting
to close in on Bernie Sanders at the national
level.
So let's look at a few different things here.
Our video audience watching on our TV affiliates
or free speech TV or on Youtube, we'll see
the polling data represented visually on screen.
You will see that the, the trajectory of Joe
Biden's polling started with, with with Biden
preannouncement polling in the mid to high
twenties and then spiking to more than 40%
average and national polls after he formally
announced that yes, he's running for president,
but then it started to not look so good.
Joe Biden trailing off from like that 41 42%
mark down to about 38% which I told you about
at the time.
He continued trailing off to around 35 and
a half or 36 he started this week down even
further around 33 or 34 in the polls and Joe
Biden has had another really bad five days
and he's now down to 32 on average, including
a low of 27% in one particular recent poll
from the economist and you Gov now earlier
on you'll notice it was Bernie Sanders who
is benefiting from Biden's drop.
In other words about six weeks ago, Bernie's
gains, we're matching Joe Biden's drop very
closely with a little bit of the Biden drop
going elsewhere, but in the last 10 days or
so, Biden has continued to drop, but Bernie
has stayed pretty even and it's Actually Been
Elizabeth Warren benefiting from the loss
of Joe Biden and slightly p booted judge who
has been climbing as Joe Biden continues to
falter.
This has been a very solid week for Elizabeth
Warren.
She's now more solidly into the double digits,
averaging about 11% in the national polls
and as I said a month ago, Oh Elizabeth Warren
had been picking up on average one to one
and a half percentage points per month.
If she continues this into the debates she
could and the keyword is could, could be in
a position to actually overtake Bernie Sanders
and later on in the program today I'm going
to address an audience question which wants
to know whether Bernie and Warren are potentially
going to sort of just split the progressive
vote and maybe hurt the progressive movement
in the long term.
I'll talk about that later on in the program.
Um, the question for Elizabeth Warren is that
the debate start will be, is she going to
be better prepared for these debates than
she has in prior circumstances?
And maybe preparation is not the right word.
She's just not a great debater.
Right.
I Love Elizabeth Warren's policy focus town
halls.
I love the detailed campaign, a policy proposals
that she has released.
I love the campaign she's running, but I recognize
that on a debate stage with, I don't know
how they're, if it's going to be nine candidates
on each of the two, they're splitting the
first two debates into two groups because
there are so many Democratic candidates.
I don't know if Elizabeth Warren on a stage
with eight other people, um, is going to do
well in a way that is actually going to help
her polling because I just don't think that's
the best sort of setting for her.
So this is national polling.
Let's look at a couple of other things, including
Iowa, because meanwhile, in Iowa, Joe Biden
is now barely leading at all.
Biden is holding an average lead of just five
points in Iowa over Bernie Sanders with a
margin of error somewhere between three and
four typically, uh, that is not particularly
good for Joe Biden.
So I believe that Iowa is effectively up for
grabs.
I don't mean Biden is losing as of today.
What I mean is it's close enough and far away
and it's, the polling is close enough and
the caucus is far away enough that the debates
could actually push Iowa to Bernie Sanders
or even potentially to somebody else, depending
on how the debates go.
Looking at New Hampshire, not surprisingly,
New Hampshire has a different sort of a, of
a theme.
New Hampshire Democrats are more establishment
centrist then Iowa caucus goers maybe.
And Joe Biden has a larger lead there.
He's plus 13.
In New Hampshire.
Iowa is the first caucus, then you, Hampshire
primary comes after that.
So there are a couple of, of different views
on these poles.
And on the 2020 primary, one view is it's
over.
If you look at June of the year before the
election, historically the leader in June
of the year before the election usually ends
up being the nominee, meaning it's Biden and
that's it.
That's one view.
Okay.
The other view is this thing is totally wide
open.
Anyone can win this and it's still early.
I think neither of you is probably the right
one here.
It is not wide open, but there is still certainly
a chance for one of the other front runners
to when historically there have been moments
in June of the year before the election where
you have one candidate polling 60% and then
a bunch of other people in the single digits.
That is not the situation this year.
You have Joe Biden dropping and only leading
Bernie Sanders by a much more modest amount
right now.
And you have multiple candidates in double
digits, uh, certainly now Biden, Sanders and
Warren.
And that could even change with Buddhist judge
or maybe even Harris as the debates get going.
So I do think that there is an opportunity
here for it to be somebody other than Joe
Biden.
I know that there are some people emailing
me who say things like, David, nothing that
has happened in the past matters this time
around because everything is different.
Trump as president, as the status quo is so
different than anything that has happened
before.
The leftward swing of, of Democratic voters
is like nothing that we've ever seen before.
Every election.
This happens every election, there's a contingent
that says nothing from the past matters because
this time it's so different.
Uh, I think that these are new circumstances,
but anybody who's pulling under 1% has done
okay.
I know people are emailing me, even saying
that people like Beto are about surge drastically.
As soon as the debate start, I don't think
so.
And he's pulling like three or 4%.
Uh, but if you're pulling under 1%, I mean,
just the dynamics are not so different this
year that, you know, I get emails from people
saying Tulsi is going to so dominate the debates
that she'll be leading after the second debate.
No, she won't.
Okay.
Beto is not all of a sudden going to take
the lead.
He, he should go back to Texas and run against
senator corn in there.
I think he's got a better shot.
It is possible for someone from the top three.
The top four may be the top five who could
pull into the lead and ultimately take this
nomination.
Historically, it's most likely to be Bernie
or Biden.
Okay.
Given where the polls are now, given how these
primaries have gone, basically every time
in history, uh, it's going to be Biden or
Bernie most likely and there is like a 99%
certainty that it will be Biden, Sanders,
Warren, Buddha, judge or Harris.
Okay.
If you're outside of that group, I don't see
how you ultimately take this nomination.
Now, that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
support someone outside of that group if that's
who you want to see.
When I believe that a diverse primary is a
good thing, I believe that you should support
whoever is most aligned with your values and
on the issues.
What I am telling you in terms of a historical
analysis is that it is extraordinarily unlikely
that anyone outside of the current top five
ultimately as the nominee, if you disagree
with me, tell me either how am I misunderstanding
the current data or how is the historical
context not relevant to what is going on this
particular time.
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and it's a good one.
It's a good one
this week.